tel est le principe de présomption
d'innocence que cet achat de première
nécessité qu'est ce que fait mme dahl
impérieux nous a finalement laissé à la
libre appréciation de l'agent hessel
nous prémunit pas contre un esprit
distrait a déclaré qu'il ne dit pas
qu'il y ait des d'erreurs et c'est parce
que je ne doutais pas qu'il y aurait des
erreurs et j'ai veillé à ce que le délai
de contestation
et c'est là où la présomption
d'innocence n'est pas respectée et à ses
problèmes
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit ce
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt
france pour une heure et demie
d'émission nous décrypterons comme
chaque soir du lundi aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenus à bonne distance et nos
reporters l'actualité toujours dominé
par la crise du coronavirus en france et
dans le monde voici les titres en france
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs du
déconfinement ce matin plus d'un million
d'enfants ont repris le chemin de
l'école dans un contexte d'épidémie des
mesures sanitaires inédites sont mises
en place dans les classes de primaire et
de maternelle une rentrée compliquée
forcément on nourrit de certaines
craintes et de doutes en europe
si le déconfinement se poursuit les
voyageurs sont promis à une quarantaine
en espagne cette mesure prendra effet
dès vendredi avec 14 jours d'isolement
pour les personnes venant de l'étranger
en russie et aux etats unis c'est la
sphère politique qui est touché par le
cos vide dans l'entourage respectifs des
présidents outre-atlantique au brésil la
situation est alarmante avec un bilan en
hausse mais le président bolle sonar or
est ouvertement corona celtique
[Musique]
c'est sans doute l'une des phases les
plus scrutés de ce déconfinement la
reprise de l'école seules les classes de
maternelle et certaines classes de
primaire étaient concernés aujourd'hui
ce sont les premiers au total environ un
million et demi d écoliers et leurs
enseignants jean michel blanquer remis
ni de l'éducation était en visite ce
matin dans une école de l'essonne il a
parlé de ce premier jour comme d'une
amorce est en ligne de mire évidemment
le respect des mesures sanitaires qui
est évidemment primordial pensée
établissements illustration à l'école
primaire hollande au hyères dans le var
avec isabelle ferrières sur un récit
d'emilie goog h
une rentrée qui se fait suivant une
procédure assez stricte dans cette école
du sud de la france
les enfants ne sont que 7 à 10 maximum
par classe et leur rentrée se fait selon
des horaires décalés du cp au cm2
l'arrivée des élèves se fait en trois
temps toutes les dix minutes pour éviter
que les enfants ne se croisent à
l'extérieur dans la cour les bancs sont
condamnés et un marquage au sol de
couleur orange est visible tous les
maîtres quant à la cantine elle sera
gratuite et financée par la mairie pour
compenser l'impact du coc vite 19 sur
certaines familles alors les parents
sont plutôt confiants
je les aurais bien expliquer les règles
et puis après en ce qui concerne l'école
ils sont tous des bons enseignants donc
ils vont faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien
elles sont un moment ou un autre il faut
il faut reprendre une vie un peu normal
donc voilà aujourd'hui
ou dans un mois ça revient au même je
fais confiance je fais confiance à
l'école à l'équipe pédagogique est
également services de la mairie donc
voilà je fais confiance je pense qu'il
fallait bouger
peut-être parce que les enfants
commençaient à être et que c'était à la
maison j'en ai discuté avec mon médecin
avec les gens autour de moi pensent que
les mesures mises en place sont bonnes
je pense qu'il devrait y avoir aucun
souci pour d'autres parents d'élèves en
revanche l'heure n'est pas tellement à
la sérénité avec la levée du confinement
beaucoup ont dû retourner au travail
le retour à l'école étaient à l'ordre
inévitable alors à 10 de 2,2 pas trop
patrons touchés de garder les distances
a amené à mettre de la distance de
sécurité dans les spéciales es et les
maîtres s'est pas vraiment rassuré non
on verra bien si ta famille et à moi
laissez les enfants qui veulent revenir
bas jeudi à l'itie en tout dans cet
établissement 47 élèves ont fait leur
rentrée ce matin l'école on accueille
normalement 130 malgré la mise en place
de mesures sanitaires des parents vous
préférez attendre le mois de juin pour
se laisser le temps d'évaluer la
situation et autres aspects du
déconfinement la réouverture des parcs
notamment à paris qui a été la source
d'une passe d'armes entre eux olivier
vers ans et anne hidalgo la maire de la
capitale a demandé la réouverture des
espaces verts dans la capitale sous
réserve de porter un masque de
protection non plus a répondu aussitôt
le ministre de la santé une demande
perçue comme une incitation à ne pas
respecter les gestes barrières selon
olivier vert non nous n'ouvrirons pas
les parcs et jardins à paris en ile de
france ainsi que dans les autres régions
qui sont classées rouge parce que non
pas qu'on n'a pas envie que les gens
puissent sortir prendre l'air mais que
ça peut être extrêmement tentant
le soleil que nous avons aujourd'hui que
les gens se regroupent trop ça mastro
qui ne respectent pas les groupes de dix
et qu'il ne reste plus pas respecté les
conditions des gestes barrières
si nous ne respectons pas collectivement
les conditions de distanciation physique
les gestes barrière alors le virus
repartira il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
ne repartent pas et si le virus doit
repartir nous serons obligés de mettre
de nouvelles contraintes pour protéger
les français
je pense que c'est une question de santé
publique de pouvoir ré ouvert nos parcs
et jardins nous sommes dans une ville
très dense et il faut permettre aux
parisiens d'avoir plus d'espacé pour
respirer
si on ferme les parcs et jardins les
gens vont se retrouver dans des endroits
qui sont soit les trottoirs soient des
lieux comme les quais quai de valmy ou
les quais de seine et cela provoque des
attroupements
parce que nous sommes une ville très
très dense je rappelle 20000 habitants
au kilomètre carré à paris en moyenne on
est une des villes les plus denses
d'europe donc c'est une question de
santé publique très parmi les mesures
prises à paris justement des
distributeurs de gel hydro alcoolique
qui ont été installés dans les rues une
initiative qui rassure plutôt les
habitants je pense que c'est une très
bonne initiative parce qu'il va falloir
protéger la vie de tout le monde donc il
est très important depuis toujours de
pouvoir se laver les mains et là encore
plus en période de crise donc à il faut
le faire et la distribution à l'idéal
parce que dans ce contexte et on en a
besoin
sauf que là il faut pousser c'est un
poussoir donc question sécurité au
niveau du buste suis pas certaine mais
bon je trouve que c'est une très bonne
initiative parce que malheureusement
tout le monde n'a pas un cube de jeunes
dans la poche et on touche énormément de
choses même sans s'en rendre compte
ne serait-ce que le visage déjà ou
l'oreille enfin peu importe
et j'espère que les gens vont respecter
elle servira aussi à tout un chacun qui
est dehors
nos personnes qui sont sans abri à
pouvoir vraiment se nettoyer à moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui cette maladie l
ouverture et la prise de conscience de
la collective pour repère attention et
il a levé progressive du déconfinement a
donc débuté mais avec des restrictions à
paris on l'aura compris situés en zone
rouge et avec une forte densité de
population
elle porte du mas transports en commun
réouverture des écoles distanciation
social gestes barrière était ce la
capitale est elle prête à ceux des
conflits nés c'est l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
aurélien véron candidat à la mairie de
paris centre pour rachida dati bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous aurélien véron à
ses côtés rémi branco ex chef de cabinet
du ministère de l'agriculteur de culture
par dont le soutien lui d'un belgo merci
à vous d'être avec nous vos premières
questions pour vous aurélien véron de
manière globale on rentrera dans le
détail est prêt selon vous anne hidalgo
est elle suffisamment anticipé cette
crise et surtout le le déconfinement le
sentiment que j'ai eu après ces deux
mois confinement c'est que elle
improvise depuis quinze jours ne
déconfinement en ayant attendu pendant
ces deux mois que quelque chose se passe
au niveau de l'état que les autorités du
délivre un message est aujourd'hui le
sec la séquence des masques sur 20 vous
savez ces fameux masque qui sont arrivés
en rouleaux de ml qui sont des masques
certainement utile pour des personnes
les journées qui sont très mal pratique
et pas adapté aux personnes âgées
c'est reconnu baab celle de l'entreprise
française qui les a fabriquées
c'est un amateurisme d'improvisation
donc nous sortons de deux mois de
confinement dans lesquelles la mairie
tarija et mêmes consignes et personne
n'a vu d'avion les rues personnes
avaient de programmes personnages ou de
masques personnes avides organisation et
aujourd'hui elle nous sort des mesures
qui sont inaptes rate suis encore des
échecs patents le coût des masques est
flagrant mais dans tous les domaines la
mobilité la fermeture de la rue de
rivoli dans deux centres de bail
auxquelles je suis confronté alors
aujourd'hui j'ai pas beaucoup de
circulation parce que les gens
reprennent le travail très doucement ça
paralyse les quatre arrondissements et
ça reporte sur les arrondissements
voisins tous les bouchons des parisiens
des personnes de banlieue qui viennent
en voiture nécessité donc tout ça c'est
très désorganisée et la confusion
malheureusement dans cette crise
s'ajoute à celle de l'état
les parisiens sont très démunis rémi
branco à un jugement un diagnostic
plutôt sévère 23 réaction alors je
partage une partie du diagnostic à
savoir qu'effectivement l'état et le
gouvernement en particulier n'ont pas
été à la hauteur des attentes que
pouvaient avoir les habitants en france
et à paris en particulier
on aurait dû prendre des mesures bien
plus tôt
pour prévoir ce déconfinement la maire
de paris à fait les propositions déjà
dès le début du mois d'avril pour
essayer d'imaginer un déconfinement
puisque à l'heure où elle l'a fait
personne ne donner des pistes pour en
sortir
donc contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
je pense vraiment que la mairie de paris
a été exemplaire et a pris la place en
quelque sorte de l'état qu'ensuite tout
ne soit pas parfait à 100 % c'est vrai
je parlais des masques et c'est vrai
qu'à une minorité de masques qui a été
adressée et qui aujourd'hui ne
correspond pas au confort que
souhaiterait notamment des personnes
âgées c'est vrai en revanche ces masques
il fonctionne la mode grande majorité
des masses qui sont distribués
aujourd'hui au parisien
il faut les encourager à aller sur
paris.fr en faire la demande
ils sont très efficaces et ils sont très
pratiques moi je mets en garde
le type de critiques qu'on a entendu de
la part de madame dati visant à dire que
des masques ne fonctionnerait pas il
faudrait pas que ce soit un message qui
pousserait les parisiens ne pas en faire
la demande
là ce serait très grave est ailleurs
c'est un manque de respect aussi pour
une belle frappe française
là j'ai juste capables à tout parce que
ce qui est vrai vous le reconnaissez oui
par ailleurs un un seul masques par
personne est ce bien suffisant sachant
également là c'est peut-être pour vous
olivier verront que voilà quand on
interroge un petit peu les parisiens à
droite à gauche selon les
arrondissements on apprend que dans le
7e ou et où rachida dati et les maires
et bien les masques sont distribués à
profusion évidemment elle est en
campagne électorale aussi donc la
politique peut-être joue un rôle que
dans certains arrondissements il faut
faire sa petite demande sur internet et
on reçoit un seul masque en tout et
pourtant sachant qu'on doit le changer
pour les quatre heures à ce que c'est
normal c'est deux poids deux mesures la
question des masques ça manque de
logistique et là nous revenions sur le
fait que l'état a été totalement à côté
de la réalité pendant au moins
moi qui a séparé le début le confinement
à aujourd'hui est donc un retard
flagrant lorsque valérie pécresse dont
l'ile-de-france commandes 2 millions de
masques pour paris et que les livres et
puis tous les maires d'arrondissement
s'organise on voit bien quelques
séquences logistique qui est anticipée à
part des maires le rôle des mairies
c'est un bol de logistique et
d'accompagnement je prends pas de la
sécurité de la mobilité de la propreté
qui est un gros tournoi dans la capitale
mais déjà la logistique est un vrai
métier est une vraie 1 mais on peut
municipal des deux collectivités
territoriales anne hidalgo c'est la
veille et reda alors est ce qu'elle est
la part du public et les masques fin
avril comme l'avait promis ou là on est
ce qu'on va pas pinailler sur les dates
c'est compliqué je ne jette pas la
pierre parce qu'encore une fois tous les
échelons de l'état en faillite
mais quand vous riegler mer comme
geoffroy boulard qui sont autant en
campagne que anne hidalgo je vous
signale tout le monde est en campagne
il s'agit pas d'une campagne il s'agit
d'une épidémie d'une pandémie mondiale
le rôle d'un maire c'est d'abord
d'anticiper et de prévoir et d'organiser
et bien je constate que les maires
notamment rachida dati a été élu premier
tour organise la logistique pid au
prétexte notamment des tests mais les a
fait des tests l'otan moulard aussi on
attendait un iphone des tests massif
dans les arrondissements pour les
personnels soignants pour les
particuliers pas dans les laboratoires
dans la rue accessible et on se rend
compte que tout ça alors le plan publié
dans la presse par anne hidalgo en avril
à fin avril est arrivé tardivement de
bonnes idées et je reconnais c'était du
copier coller plus que les allemands
font donc c'est plutôt un plan qui est
intéressant mais où sont les actes le
mobilier urbain n'a jamais été nettoyée
dans l'arrondissement 1er et 2e je n'ai
pas vu de nettoyage pendant deux mois
les détritus s'accumulent et les sdf ont
reçu des sanisettes il ya quinze jours
les sdr qui n'avaient plus accès aux
banques qui étaient fermés et plus accès
aux services de secours qui est
également à l'abandon complet
on a vu les sanisettes rempli de
seringue de capote d'un bordel
innommable
les fds n'ont reçu leur sanisettes
mobile que ya quinze jours donc tout ça
est très improvisé on
général d'armée à la mairie de paris on
a un lieu de non votre réponse serait
lié à branco non c'est malheureusement
bon je suis un peu affligé par ce genre
de critiques
désolé de le dire mais quand on parle
des sdf il a fallu s'organiser en
premier lieu pour leur trouver des
logements pour leur trouver des lieux
d'accueil c'est ce qui a été fait dans
des gymnases
il a fallu aussi par la défaillance de
l'état compensé le manque des cantines
la fermeture des cantines pour
énormément de familles ces trente mille
familles populaires parisienne qui ont
eu grâce à la mairie de paris
les aides financières pour pouvoir
donner à manger à leurs enfants l'état
l'a promis on attend toujours la date le
montant de ces aides
la mairie de paris l'a proposé à une
dalle gaulle a fait ces familles là
aujourd'hui
elles ont des aides directes pour
pouvoir manger ce qu'ils étaient il ya
un mois un des principaux une des
principales craintes des pouvoirs
publics à savoir que une crise sociale
voire une crise alimentaire allait
toucher de nombreuses familles modestes
choix qu'il il faut vraiment sûr c'est
être très humble tout ne peut pas être
parfait
tout ne peut pas être anticipé une dans
une crise dont le sait sans précédent
les municipalités font ce qu'elles
peuvent s'agissant des sdf je trouve
pour le coup que la polémique est mal
choisi puisque vraiment ces populations
la ruhr était à risque
les marocains n'ont pas pu se faire
normalement pendant de nombreux jours
voire semaines est vraiment la mairie de
paris a fait tout ce qu'elle pouvait
pour accueillir au mieux ces populations
et aider celles qui pouvait ne plus
nourrir leurs enfants faute de cantine
alors l'une des grandes actualités du
jour c'est évidemment la reprise des
écoles seuls 15% des écoliers parisiens
font leur rentrée le 14 mai selon anne
hidalgo
c'était une rentrée trop précoce selon
vous aurélien véron au contraire on a eu
raison quel est votre votre réaction sur
cette reprise de l'école à paris
aujourd'hui où cette tombe le virus sera
toujours là donc il ya un moment il faut
reprendre
il faut font doucement jour expérimenté
ne manquent pas aujourd'hui sont un peu
dans la confusion ce n'est pas simple
aucune
encore une fois entre alors ça dépend si
on part du primaire le secondaire mais
l'organisation de la rentrée était quand
même chaotique
là je jette la pierre à personne parce
que et du golfe et des académies comme
du point de vue de la mairie paris c'est
des sujets lourds il faut de la
concertation des enseignants les
directeurs d'école non c'est très
compliqué il fallait reprendre l'école
c'est une bonne chose
les enfants ont besoin de reprendre le
fil de l'enseignement de l'éveil de mort
sociale et de l'apprentissage des
fondamentaux
il fallait pas attendre c'était une
bonne chose de commencer même réaction
rien verrons il fallait reprendre
l'école c'était important
alors oui il fallait reprendre l'école
et en même temps là aussi je partage
totalement ce qui a été dit par monsieur
verrons on ne pouvait pas de faire du
jour au lendemain une rentrée complète
avec 100% des élèves on pouvait pas non
plus dire qu'on attendait septembre il
fallait que cette rentrée commence à se
faire et va se faire progressivement
avec une adaptation à la fois des
personnels municipaux des enseignants
eux mêmes
et puis là aussi c'est quand même
compliqué pour des parents qui sont mis
devant une responsabilité qui est lourde
avec cette scolarisation sur la base du
volontariat
est-ce que je mets en danger mes enfants
en les emmenant à l'école est ce que
voilà est-ce que pour l'heure bien je
dois les amener ou pas à l'école bon
c'est des sujets qui sont lourds et je
crois que ça peut ne se remettre en
place vraiment que progressivement jour
après jour semaine après semaine c'est
qu'un début à la fois pour les crèches
les écoles et les collégiens
voilà espérons que rapidement tout le
monde prenne ses marques
aurélien véron l'organisation des
conférences tout à l'heure les listes
prioritaires est ce que c'est une bonne
chose selon vous vous comprenez que ce
soit aussi compliqué à vivre pour
certains parents certains peuvent mettre
leurs enfants d'autres noms pour voir
des raisons de métiers notamment une
proposition qui a été faite par les
théâtres de la ville de paris théâtre pu
priver notamment c'était de mettre à
disposition leurs salles qui sont
inutilisables pour que les classes qui
sont petits effectifs puis se disperser
dans des espaces différents avec des
questions sanitaires impeccable le
croate les enfants soient mis en danger
mais des grands espaces
quatre tours est ma disposition
moyennant un financement qui va toutes
façons de voir venir
si nous voulons la survie de nos
théâtres privés mais donc y aller il ya
des propositions d'acteurs de la vie de
paris privé qui sont prêts à suppléer le
nombre des spas sont des écoles donc il
faut que très rapidement alors la montée
en charge et progressive parce qu'une
test on expérimente on rassure et les
enseignants prennent leurs repères ils
sont quand même très rapidement que tous
les élèves puissent aller à l'école
parce que l'inégalité qui naîtrait
effectivement d'un d'un décrochage de
ceux qui n'ont pas accès à l'école par
rapport à ce qui serait privilégiée sera
très vite intenable et je crois qu'il
est de leur devoir de la mairie de paris
au moins dans primaire de n'assurer que
le maximum d'élèves très vite et accès à
l'école par souci d'égalité
encore une fois les espaces existe il ya
des acteurs qui composent lorraine
essayons de coordonnées et c'est là que
je pense qu'il faut un général d'armée
qui était qu'il soit prêt à entendre
très vite dans l'action tous ces acteurs
pour s'organiser
je pense que ce serait de commencer bien
avant les propositions sont apparus b
abrite 1 et aida aujourd'hui entre est
leader il n'est jamais trop tard il faut
s'organiser mais encore une fois la
mairie n'est pas seul il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs privés qui sont prêts à aider
qu'ils ont plein d'idées qui ont besoin
d aide
mais on échange des êtres humains le que
l'état où la ville de paris va leur
apporter
ils sont prêts à porter aussi le renne
logistique passoire pratique des espaces
pour les écoles et d'autres acteurs un
dernier thème messieurs quitterait le
débat en tout cas en train ni les lbo et
le ministre de la santé
rémi branco anne hidalgo qui dit
l'ouverture des portes est une question
de santé publique
alors on a vu un des images vous allez
nous donner leur avis votre avis là
dessus sur le canal saint martin des
français des jeunes français qui se sont
rassemblés effectivement se demandent où
ils peuvent se rassembler ouverture des
parcours imagine que vous êtes pour
comme anne hidalgo
rémi branco moi je suis évidemment pour
à la fois en tant que parisien
parce que quand on est confiné par deux
mois dans un appartement petit a
fortiori quand on est une famille
nombreuse
le fait d'avoir accès les espaces se
soit déjà l'air libre mais en plus des
espaces où on peut respirer comme les
parcs
c'est quelque chose d'important mais
aussi c'est important pour limiter la
programme la propagation du virus
ce qu'on a vu sur le canal saint martin
c'est la résultante directe du manque
des espaces verts du
espace où on peut marcher ça à errer
sans être sur un trottoir de boulevard
ou d'un venu à faire respirer les pots
d'échappement à ses enfants donc je
pense justement qu'en voyant ces images
du canal saint martin le ministre de la
santé aurait dû en déduire qu'il fallait
augmenter le nombre d' espaces
disponibles pour les parisiens en
revanche ça doit évidemment se faire
dans le dialogue avec la préfecture
mais dans le sérieux et la rigueur qu'on
doit pas dire aux habitants de paris
allez-y aller dans les parcs aller
pique-niquer réunissez-vous alesi à 20 à
30 morts il faudra des règles très
strictes en contrôle policier qui soit
très ferme
oui les parisiens doit avoir accès au
parc de la ville de paris mais dans des
conditions les plus strictes pour qu'on
n'ait pas de propagation du virus
comme on a pu le voir sur internet saint
martin tout cas manifestement c'est non
pour eux olivier ferrand pour l'instant
aurélien véron sur ce point alors sur ce
point mal je vais rejoindre la position
du clan hidalgo je crois aussi et je les
exprime et qu'il faut absolument ouvrir
les pattes jardin j'aurais aimé cadets
d'impôt défend d'ouverture des marchés
de rue parce qu'encore une fois toutes
les activités en extérieur sont beaucoup
moins dangereux que les activités en
intérieur
aller dans un magasin fermé c'est plus
dangereux que jamais les courses dans un
magasin ouvert et notamment les marchés
de rue notamment alors aujourd'hui avec
des pâtes oui faut les ouvrir il a du
mal à comprendre qu un ministre qui a
cafouillé dans sa politique de santé
depuis deux mois impose à la ville de
paris ces conditions alors que la ville
de paris est en train de remettre en
activité les agents de la ville de paris
met du gel et même si je dénonçais une
confusion dans la gestion de ce
confinement et du post continent le
porte aujourd'hui tout le monde est prêt
on a besoin de ces barques parce que les
rues sont insuffisantes on est la ville
la plus dense d'europe
nous allons 20me habitants au kilomètre
carré tous les jours de la banlieue
viennent des travailleurs qui viennent
presque augmenté de 20 à 30%
cette densité peut-être moins
aujourd'hui parce que le travail reprend
progressivement
mais ça veut dire qu'on est plus de 22
23 25 mille habitants au kilomètre carré
d'honneur et les environs rémi branco
des années on arrive
l'issue de ce débat merci à vous d'avoir
été en direct sur rt france et pour ceux
qui sont déjà élus le gouvernement a
donné son feu vert à l'installation des
conseils municipaux élus au premier tour
organisé dont vous souvenez le 15 mars
dernier au plus tard pour donc le 28 mai
mais quid des villes où le premier tour
on n'a pas suffi à dégager une majorité
les explications en images
[Musique]
au plus tard le jeudi 28 mai trente
mille des 35000 communes françaises
auront un conseil municipal installé et
un maire et des adjoints élus dans les
conditions normales et je pense que nous
pouvons tous nous en féliciter
[Musique]
m
et pour parler de ses conseils
municipaux nous sommes avec yves
d'amécourt d'amécourt bonsoir alors vous
vous n'êtes plus candidats le 15 mars
votre adjointe sylvie penchons a été
battu par le candidat de et les filles
de 32 voix au premier tour de l'élection
municipale de sauveterre de guyenne
environ dont vous étiez le maire les
républicains vous souhaitez vous qu'un
nouveau scrutin soit tenu pour quelles
raisons c'est très simple nous sommes un
certain nombre de d'élus de toute la
france à avoir constaté la désaffection
des bureaux de vote le 15 mars notamment
due aux messages sanitaires du
coronavirus le discours du président de
la république le jeudi soir le discours
du premier ministre le samedi soir qui
fait qu'un certain nombre de personnes
sont restées chez elles les personnes
avec une santé fragile les personnes qui
voulaient pas porter le virus à des
membres de leur famille les personnes
qui étaient confinés dans les maisons de
retraite avec interdiction d'en sortir
et donc nous estimons que le scrutin n'a
pas été conforme à l'article 3 de la
constitution puisque tous les français
n'étaient pas égaux devant les
opérations de vote contrairement à ce
que la loi d'urgence coe vide qui a été
voté par le parlement a dit ensuite ça
veut dire quoi concrètement
il va damer cour que le scrutin pour
vous n'était pas sincère comme on l'a
souvent dit voilà donc en fait
aujourd'hui vous avez un certain nombre
de spécialistes de la constitution qui
qui remettent en cause la sincérité du
scrutin et depuis d'ailleurs la loi sur
les faits que news qui a été voté par le
parlement et la majorité actuelle est
apparue une nouvelle notion dans la
danse en outre dans notre arsenal
législatif qui est la sincérité national
et nous pensons que le conseil
constitutionnel devrait être interrogé
sur cette sincérité du scrutin du 15
mars
c'est pour ça qu'un certain nombre de
nos adhérents dans toute la france ont
déposé des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité avec leurs
protestations plus de 3000 protestation
dans toute la france et donc nous
souhaitons que le conseil d'état puisse
se transmettre ces questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité très
rapidement au conseil constitutionnel
laurent fabius il ya quinze jours a dit
qu'il attendait ces qpc pour que le
conseil constitutionnel puisse se
prononcer sur un certain nombre de
questions et donc qu'il serait
intéressant que cela soit fait et que
cela soit fait avant que le premier
ministre ne l'organisent l'installation
des conseils municipaux alors
l'installation des conseils municipaux
justement c'est l'information de la
journée qu'il est seront installés au
plus tard le 28 mai c'est une décision
du coup que vous vous contestez mais que
nous contestons avant et que nous allons
que nous allons contester dès que le
produit aura pris sa décision
nous ferons un arrêté suspendant un
référé suspension pour suspendre la
décision du premier ministre
en attendant que le conseil
constitutionnel puisse se prononcer sur
sur ces élections du 15 mars
ce sont à peu près 30% de l'électorat
habituel des élections municipales qui
ne sont pas venus voter c'est énorme
les maires sont les élus préférés des
français parce qu'ils sont bien élu
parce que la participation aux élections
municipales
habituellement être est haute et cette
fois ci ça n'a pas été le cas il ya même
des maires comme par exemple le ministre
des comptes publics gérald darmanin qui
a été élu dans sa ville avec 15% des
inscrits s'étaient c'est à dire que
c'est très peu et la légitimité d'un élu
avec 15% des inscrits est très très
basse si votre adjointe avait été
gagnante on n'avait pas été battu est ce
que vous auriez réagi de la même manière
j'en sais rien je fais pas de la fiction
mais en tout cas le combat que nous
menons avec tous ces élus de france
d'ailleurs il ya avec nous des gens qui
ont été élus au premier tour et qui
contestent leur propre élection parce
qu'ils estiment que leur légitimité
n'est pas la même qu'avec une élection
normale
le fait d'avoir organisé ce premier tour
pour le gouvernement certains parlent
d'une faute politique
il ya eu effectivement ça a été prouvé
par la suite des victimes liées en tout
cas cette journée d'élections aussi bien
dans la campagne que au niveau de
l'organisation le jour même de
l'élection à ce que vous partagez ce
diagnostic de fautes politiques dont
devra répondre le gouvernement moi je
pense que c'est une faute d'avoir en
même temps mais c est la devise de notre
président annoncé que l'on entré dans la
phase 3 de la pandémie est organisée
tout de même les élections municipales
moi j'ai des membres de ma famille qui
habite dans la sarthe qui ont été qui
ont eux qui ont pris le virus du coc vie
de 19 le jour de l'élection c'est le cas
de ma maman qui a qui a eu le corona
virus qui a 81 ans qui aujourd'hui est
sorti de de cette histoire et elle est
très fière d'être dans notre sortie mais
voilà j'ai quatre ou cinq membres de ma
famille qui ont eu le coït 19 le jour du
vote
si ce premier tour ne devait pas être
annulé ce qu'ils sont en mains quand
même probable le second tour vous le
souhaiteriez pour qu'on parle du 21 juin
de septembre l'association des maires de
france voudrait la deuxième quinzaine de
septembre et vous en fait si vous voulez
dans l'avis du conseil d'état qui avait
été formulée avant l'annulation du
deuxième tour le conseil d'état disait
que si cette élection ne vais pas lieu
au mois de juin il faudrait annuler le
premier tour et donc si aujourd'hui
christian jacob et gérard larcher
demande que l'élection ait lieu en juin
c'est bien parce qu'ils craignent que le
premier tour soit annulé et si on annule
le premier tour dans une partie des
communes de france
on aura beaucoup de mal à justifier
qu'on le maintienne dans les autres donc
en fait aujourd'hui on est dans une
espèce de course à l'échalote
nous nous pensons que l'urgence c'est la
crise du couronne virus et que les plus
habilités pour s'en occuper ce sont les
maires élus qui ont l'expérience est
donc le plus simple et le plus facile le
plus le plus serein serait d'annuler
tout simplement ces élections est de le
repousser en septembre ou en mars après
la après la pandémie
merci beaucoup
dès mes courts d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france mais eux dénoncent
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui à leurs
yeux je cite piétine arbitrairement les
libertés de chacun il a été validé en
tout cas par le conseil constitutionnel
jusqu'au 10 juillet des avocats se sont
rassemblés en fin d'après-midi place
vendôme et se sont regroupés face au
ministère de la justice pour exprimer
leur colère sur ces images on peut voir
une dizaine d'avocats scandant des
slogans pancartes et fumigènes dans les
mains ou il réclame donc le
rétablissement de l'état de droit en
france + puis libéré la crise sanitaire
l'état d'urgence ya eu donc en fait
actuellement il y a eu un plan je dirais
d'arrêt total de toutes les juridictions
hormis je dirais les juridictions
pénales est encore dans des conditions
catastrophiques on disait pour les
activités simplement essentiel
donc en fait rien n'a marché et dans les
juridictions pénales
il y avait des problèmes de plus
concernés des mesures de l'ue et bien
c'était soit dévolue des procédures sans
autre évoluant sans débat sans avocat
et en fait depuis 1793 détresse et la
première fois où en fait on pouvait
prolonger la m sont provisoires sans un
juge c'est une des illustrations de la
contagiosité ducobu de 19 l'équipage du
porte-avions charles de gaulle a été
fortement touchée par l'épidémie
si aujourd'hui la quasi-totalité des
marins aguerris la propagation au sein
du bâtiment militaire posant certain
nombre de questions notamment sur le
périlleux exercice de communication du
ministère des armées
thomas bonnet pour les explications on
commence d'abord par une bonne nouvelle
les marins du porte avions charles de
gaulle sont presque tous hors de danger
sur les 1700 membres de l'équipage 1046
avait été testé positif
tous sont aujourd'hui guérie sauf un une
issue heureuse à un épisode de
contamination particulièrement important
une fois le virus à bord du navire
militaire la propagation il a été
fulgurante touchant ainsi la grande
majorité des marins y compris 70% de
l'état major
beaucoup de questions s'accumulent est
alors au sujet des circonstances d'une
telle contamination dans un bâtiment si
stratégique des débats alimenté
notamment par les déclarations sous
couvert d'anonymat d'un certain marc
elle l'armée a joué avec notre santé
notre vie
les mesures barrières étaient difficiles
à respecter à bord du porte avions nous
aurions dû rester à brest tout ça manque
de transparence
auditionné par la commission de la
défense à l'assemblée nationale la
ministre des armées a pu donner quelques
explications
elle est notamment revenu sur l'impact
de la levée des mesures de distanciation
physique au sein de l'équipage
le 30 mars le commandement après la
décision d'assouplir les mesures de
distanciation très strictes qui avaient
été instaurés cette décision a été
provoqué d'une part en raison de la
baisse de moral de l'équipage et ses
conséquences sur la mission et d'autre
part sans doute par un excès de
confiance du commandement ainsi que de
son service médical dans sa mairie
de la situation au regard des
informations dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui
et j'insiste sur ce terme aujourd'hui il
y a eu des erreurs dans l'appréciation
des mesures à prendre pour combattre le
coronavirus un exercice de transparence
qui intervient après plusieurs épisodes
délicats pour la ministre des armées
ces derniers jours l'association des
journalistes de défense alertait sur des
dérives dans les relations entre
l'institution et leur profession il ya
eu également la sphère du porte-avions
la contamination dé de l'équipage du
charles de gaulle qui a qui a défrayé la
chronique dans nos rangs et qui continue
de la défrayer certains disent que
l'institution nhân a qu'à communiquer
des informations inexactes pouvoir voire
même mensongère depuis la ministre des
armées a promis une réunion pour
clarifier les choses
conséquence ou non florence par les
présentait ce mardi un nouveau bilan
chiffré
on apprend ainsi que 1771 cas confirmés
ont été détectés au sein des armées
françaises et que cinq mille quatre
cents autres cas probables ont été
également relevés autre dossier sensible
pour le ministère des armées les
témoignages de participants français aux
jeux militaires de wuhan qui se sont
déroulés en octobre dernier
elodie clouvel pentathlètes tricolore
expliqué il ya peu à nos confrères de
télévision loire cet être tombé malade
rentrant de cet événement de quoi
s'interroger sur les circonstances du
retour des sportifs sur le territoire
français depuis consignes auraient été
données aux athlètes participants de ne
plus s'exprimer sur le sujet une
nouvelle illustration du malaise qui
peut exister au sein du ministère des
armées dont la communication est
décidément compliquée
la france est d'ailleurs pas le seul
pays à ferrailler avec ces
considérations
on a tous en mémoire la gestion pour le
moins délicate de la situation à bord du
porte avions américain us s theodore
roosevelt où un grand nombre de marins
avait là aussi été infectées les
explications de la ministre des armées
ne lève pas toutes les interrogations
c'est l'avis de bastien lachaud député
et les filles de seine saint denis
membre de la commission défense à
l'assemblée nationale
le problème n'est pas tant la gestion de
la crise que le fait que des personnes
malades aient pu accéder au bâtiment et
le fait que ce qu'elle nous a dit elle
n'a été au courant des problèmes du
charles de gaulle que le lendemain de
l'airé de passion le deux soldats on
parle d'un du porte-avions de notre seul
porte avions
on parle d'un élément de notre
dissuasion nucléaire et la ministre de
la défense est informé de la présence du
corps d'un virus le lendemain de
l'évacuation des soldats mais il ya un
véritable problème où elle nous a menti
elle était au courant à voir et c'est un
problème ou et c'est le plus
vraisemblable elle ne nous a pas menti
il n'a été informé qu'à ce moment là
mais à quoi sert-elle si elle n'est même
pas capable de savoir ce qui se passe au
sein du de notre portail où il ya un
véritable problème au sein de ce
ministère sur la communication et sur
l'accès aux informations et à des
informations vérifiables temps pour la
presse que pour les parlementaires qui
sont constitutionnellement chargée de
vérifier et de contrôler l'action
d'exécuter et pour en parler nous sommes
avec dominique traque ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'onu bonsoir général merci d'être avec
nous en direct par téléphone sur rtl
france florence parly qui évoque donc
des erreurs mais pas de faute
responsables mais pas coupables quelle
est la nuance dans le fond alors avant
de parler de la nuance parlons des faits
le premier fait intéressant qui a été
soulevé que j'ai pas entendu dans votre
reportage
qu'est que là la première contamination
au virus s'est fait en fait au mois de
février dans la méditerranée à ce moment
là il est probable que l'équipage et
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'erreurs
d'appréciation le commandement se
référer aux épidémies antérieures h1n1
en particulier ni vous ni moins au mois
de février une savions exactement ce que
c'était l'honneur aux navires us si
tenté que nous le sachions aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs et donc les mesures qui ont
été prises à l'époque ont été prises en
fonction des connaissances
ce que le commandement avait d'une
épidémie de type grippal donc
effectivement aujourd'hui on dit qu'il
ya une erreur d'appréciation
ça veut dire concrètement directement
vous dites premier cas en février en
méditerranée il aurait peut-être fallu
suspens de la mission poteau alors le
porte-avions je vous parlais est pas par
hasard du h1n1 parce qu'ils avaient été
contaminés à l'époque et level qui avait
été prise avait permis de sauvegarder
l'équipage et de continuer la mission
donc les mêmes mesures ont été
appliquées
mais malheureusement l'épidémie n'avait
rien à voir mais à l'époque au mois de
février il ne le savait pas alors
ensuite et bien sûr il ya les jeux call
la fameuse escale de de brest qui
arrivait en plus tôt en fin de mission
pour le porte avions et donc les mesures
qui avaient été prises avant l'échéance
penser qu'il n'y avait pas de
propagation et là effectivement il ya
une propagation plus importante avec
comme vous le disiez l'évacuation en
particulier d'un marin à copenhague
alors la ministre a également évoqué un
excès de confiance 1 fasse encore un
virus de la part du du commandant du
charles de gaulle
est ce que ce n'est pas surprenant tout
de même de parler d'excès de confiance
pour un un militaire sachant que cette
épidémie elle date quand même voilà
d'avant on avait le retour d'expérience
de la chine tout de même elles auront
février on avait pas tellement
souvenez vous c'est arrivé vraiment fin
février début mars
et effectivement à l'époque il ya eu une
appréciation d'ailleurs il n'y a pas on
ne parle pas du commandement du ben du
bateau on parle du commandement de façon
générale et du service de santé il faut
savoir que le rendement bien sûr assisté
par des médecins
donc il ya eu une erreur d'appréciation
c'est certain à l'époque sur le porte
avions globalement et donc les mesures
n'ont peut-être pas été prise compte
tenu de la gravité de ceux qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui de coronavirus alors
laquelle un 14 n imposait à bord prenait
fin le 30 mars en le sport a repris à
bord il ya même eu un concert organisé
pour remobiliser
l'équipage là aussi selon vous est ce
qu'on peut parler d'erreur de jugement
mais oui mais alors si vous voulez il
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on dit
vous noterez que le l'équipage a été
totalement tester quand il était à
toulon il a été mis en 14 n est
aujourd'hui l'équipage est sorti et
quasiment aucun membre de l'équipage n'a
été vraiment malade je ne sais pas si
vous si moi n'avons pas compte à quel
coronavirus mois au mois de février
j'ai une forte grippe mal dans le dos
j'ai pas été testée c'était peut-être
coronavirus qui s'est arrêtée là
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de l'équipage
1700 personnel de l'équipage il y à un
marin qui a été en réanimation et qui en
est sorti aujourd'hui
donc si vous voulez il faut garder la
mesure des choses et mais il reste
évident que des bateaux ont une
promiscuité est telle qu'il faut se
méfier et que probablement
l'appréciation n'a pas été fait au bon
moment et le bateau a bien fait de
rentrer en tout cas pour pouvoir tester
l'ensemble de l'équipage et rassurer
tout le monde sur le fait que d'abord il
n'y a pas de malades très grave sauf un
je le répète et qu' il n'y a eu aucune
perte dans l'équipage a désormais on
parle de test systématique avant de
partir en mission c'est une bonne chose
ça râle mais dit de belles situations
oui où il avait raison aujourd'hui on
part de test et encore une fois il ya
trois mois on ne prévoyait pas à ces
choses là
aujourd'hui il y as tests avant de
partir en opération c'est très important
pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison c'est que d'envoyer des gens qui
ne sont pas malades en opération ils ont
besoin de toutes leurs capacités
la deuxième c'est que les pays dans
lesquels les gens vont en opération ne
soit pas contaminée donc il est très
important effectivement de tester et
aujourd'hui les forces qui se prépare au
savon des préparations opérationnelles
et dans ses préparations opérationnelles
il ya une période de 14 m et il ya en
plus des tests pour s'assurer qu'on
n'envoie personne malade en opération
merci général de mithra comment d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
hamon à présent sur le bilan de
l'épidémie du coronavirus dans
l'hexagone près de 27000 décès au total
selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé 348 personnes sont
mortes en 24 heures le nombre de
patients en réanimation continue de
baisser avec 170 malades en moins le
nombre de personnes guéries et sortie
d'hôpital s'établit à 57 1785 depuis le
début de l'épidémie la situation en
prison dans le reste de l'europe on ex
panien des mesures de quarantaine vont
donc être mise en place à partir de
vendredi pour toute personne entrant sur
le territoire
l'objectif rennais donc la propagation
du virus les explications sur place de
notre correspondante à barcelone
l'oesling là à partir de vendredi toutes
les personnes qui entrent en espagne
donc ils proviennent de pays étrangers
sont soumises d'inconscient obligatoire
de 14 jours cette nouvelle mesure vise à
freiner la propagation du coronavirus
sur le territoire espagnol
il ya très peu d'exceptions seuls les
travailleurs transfrontaliers
les transporteurs et le personnel de
santé n'ayant pas eu de contact avec des
cas de kobe de 19 ne sont pas soumis à
ce confinement
ça concerne donc toutes les personnes
qui entrent en espagne même les
européens
même les résidents et même les espagnols
alors dès leur arrivée les voyageurs
doivent se confiner à leur domicile ou
dans un logement
ils peuvent sortir de chez eux
uniquement pour acheter des produits
alimentaires pharmaceutiques ou deux
cité ils sont également autorisés à
sortir pour des rendez vous médicaux ou
en cas de force majeure pour tous ses
déplacements le port du masque est
obligatoire
les autorités sanitaires peuvent
également suivre ces personnes confinées
à leur domicile par téléphone donc à
distance si ces personnes confinées ont
des symptômes comme de la toux chèvres
des problèmes respiratoires
elles doivent contacter un hôpital alors
cette nouvelle mesure
vigueur dans tout l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence est pour l'instant
décrété jusqu'au 24 mai en espagne mais
il pourra être prolongée mais ont aussi
le coeur du pouvoir touché par la crise
le porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il se faisait
soigner à l'hôpital en raison d'une
infection ans kobe 19 plus de précision
avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine frérot le porte-parole de
vladimir poutine a prévenu l'agencé de
presse russe ria novosti qu'on lui avait
diagnostiqué le corona virus et qu'il
était actuellement hospitalisé alors ce
n'est pas le premier homme politique
russe être contaminé le corona virus a
été diagnostiqué entre autres sur le
premier ministre mirail meshoe steam le
30 avril
celui ci a été remplacé dans ses
fonctions par le premier vice premier
ministre andré beloussov il ya aussi la
ministre de la culture olga ljubi move a
ainsi que le ministre la construction
vladimir iakounine f1 son adjoint
dimitri volkov
la question qu'on peut cependant se
poser est la suivante quel contact le
porte parole at il eu avec le président
ces dernières semaines alors dmitri
peskov a déclaré lui même aujourd'hui à
lagence passes il n'a pas parlé en
personne au chef de l'état depuis plus
d'un mois
l'avenir poutine se trouve en effet dans
sa résidence de novo ogarevo dans la
banlieue ouest de moscou depuis le début
de la période de confinement à
l'exception de ceux 5 19 mai où il s'est
rendu au kremlin pour les célébrations
du 75e anniversaire de la victoire
soviétique sur l'allemagne et la russie
qui est devenue le deuxième pays au
monde le plus touché par le kobe 19 ans
nombre de cas avec 232 1243 personnes
infectées selon le dernier comptage de
l' agence france-presse
depuis une dizaine de jours plus de dix
mille cartes sont recensés
quotidiennement en termes de décès le
pays compte 2000 116 morts et c'est
beaucoup moins en tout cas qu aux
etats-unis où le pays régis plus de 80
mille décès là bas aussi le coeur du
pouvoir et toucher des conseillers de la
maison blanche ont notamment été testé
positif aux comme ils disent
parmi eux un militaire employé au
service de donald trump est le porte
parole chargé du port audacieuse auprès
du vice président mike pence
le chef de la garde nationale a lui
aussi été testé positif le personnel
employé dans l'est l'ouest de la maison
blanche a reçu l'ordre de porter les
masques en permanence quand il se trouve
dans le bâtiment
de son côté le président américain lui
refuse toujours de porter un masque en
public c'était sont jusqu'ici négatif et
dans cette crise du coronavirus une voie
pour le moins singulière c'est celle du
président brésilien jaillir molson araud
il refuse de décréter le confinement une
situation inquiétante dans un pays de
210 millions d'habitants où beaucoup
d'entre eux n'ont pas accès à des
conditions d'hygiène acceptables
les précisions de clémence putallaz
c'est un appel à l'aide sur les pare
chocs de leur bus scolaire
ces conducteurs de sao paulo réclament
l'aide du gouvernement pour faire face à
la crise économique qui gagne le pays en
même temps que celle du coronavirus mais
génial also know pour qui le convie dix
neuf n'est qu'une grippette a engagé un
bras de fer contre la majorité des
gouverneurs du pays ces derniers ont
interdit les activités commerciales et
les services publics non essentiels pour
faire face au virus eu ce qu'un boost
haute dose ont traversé tous le pire
moment de la pandémie mais ça n'est pas
reconnue vue compris identifiés par tous
ceux qui se sont aveuglés par la haine
ou l'ambition personnelle mais dani filc
a calé ce qui est ancien google web os
et à gauche quand même des salles de
soins est emballé aussi rouvrir à
l'économie dès que possible au bon
moment vu de la bonne façon et tout en
respectant la science une crise
sanitaire devenu donc politique
à l'image de cette scène où le prix
brésiliens insiste un rassemblement
contre les mesures de distanciation
sociale ironie du sort jaillir bol sonar
au tous à plusieurs reprises lors de son
discours en face aux contestataires
le brésil s'enfonce également dans une
crise sociale le coronavirus contribue à
creuser le fossé entre les brésiliens
aisés et les pauvres habitants dans des
favelas ce ici dans les rues de la
capitale économique sao paulo les
habitants les plus pauvres s'organisent
comme ils peuvent
cette situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés maintenant ne fait que
souligner le grand drame des inégalités
il y avait un message sur les réseaux
sociaux qui illustre cela nous ne
pouvons pas dire que tout le monde est
dans le même bateau
nous pouvons dire que nous évoluons dans
la même mère certains sont sur leur
yacht tandis que les autres nages notre
pire problème est le manque de logements
si nous avions une maison j'y resterai
pendant la quarantaine je ne serai pas
dans la rue le cornet les rues ce n'est
qu'un problème de plus auquel nous
sommes confrontés rester confinés chez
soi se laver les mains ou encore
utiliser un masque
autant de recommandations presque
impensable pour ceux qui vivent dans les
rues du pays
c'est un séjour à sao paulo 22 sans abri
serait mort du virus dans les rues du
poumon économique du brésil
la situation au brésil nous sommes avec
à augusta leonardi journaliste
indépendant bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous tout d'abord un mot sur cette
situation sanitaire du brésil
quelle est elle alors le bilan sanitaire
s'est beaucoup alourdi ces dernières
semaines le brésil comptent davantage de
victimes du corps on a vu ce que la
chine et l'italie soit plus de 160 à
10000 personnes infectées par le col et
sachant que nous n'avons toujours pas
atteint le pic de de la maladie qui est
prévue seulement pour le mois de juillet
mais il est difficile à croire à ces
chiffres officiels car nous n'avons pas
assez de test dans le pays et selon les
chercheurs brésiliens
le nombre de personnes infectées serait
plus d'un million de cas donc la
situation est d'autant plus inquiétante
que les services publics de santé sont
désormais à déborder dans plusieurs
grandes villes du pays comme à rio ou
alors dans la région nord-est ou encore
dans la région de l'amazonie et même si
la courbe de victimes n'arrête pas de
grimper à depuis quelques semaines on
aperçoit de plus en plus de personnes
dans la rue et on les personnes
respectent de moins en moins
les mesures de confinement alors jailli
robot et sonar audouy ne semble pas
prendre la mesure de la crise c'est bien
ça oui exactement il continue de nier la
gravité de la situation et continue de
refuser d'instaurer un confinement
complet dans le pays et ces dernières
semaines il a lille s'est offert des
bains de foule il a dit plusieurs fois
que la crise serait plus de mal à la
poche du pays qu'est la santé des
brésiliens comment justement réagissent
ces derniers les brésiliens face à ces
propos de leur président alors il y a
trois le brésil a divisé en trois
parties un 3e cas il y a une grande
partie de la population qui suit les pas
de bol sonar ou quoi qu'il dise alors
que le pays est en plein chaos sanitaire
donc un tiers de la population continue
de nier la gravité ou alors même de dire
que le virus n'existe pas et il reste
fidèle à tous que molson à roddy pour
d'autres le plus important c'est de
rouvrir les commerces parce que la
plupart des brésiliens 40 millions de
brésiliens pardon independent du
commerce informel donc ils se sont
retrouvés sans travail du jour au
lendemain et il ne s'en inquiète pas
ça de la maladie et une troisième partie
de la population est extrêmement
inquiète ces personnes-là respecte le
confinement instauré par les gouverneurs
et craignent une vraie hécatombe dans
les prochaines semaines car ils voient
que le pays est complètement dans un
plonger complètement dans un dans un
chaos sanitaires et sociales on sait que
le pays et le brésil est un pays pauvre
quelles sont les conséquences
économiques sur place s'il ya t-il tout
de même certaines aides de l'état
mais exactement il y a eu une aide
établi par l'état 200 e rose qui est
très très peu car le coût de vie au
brésil est très très très élevé et cette
aide n'a pas aidé toute la population
brésilienne a défavorisé 17 millions de
personnes sont toujours à la tante de
cette aide qui n'est toujours pas arrivé
et n'ont toujours pas vu cet argent sur
leurs propres bancaires est-ce qu'il ya
très inquiet parce que plus de 10
millions de personnes et ça nous savons
déjà 10 millions de brésiliens ont perdu
leur emploi à cause de la crise donc la
plupart comme disait le prêtre dans le
sujet juste avant cela va creuser les
inégalités sociales et la pauvreté le
taux de chômage etc
on a entendu le discours de dissolution
du congrès également le soutien du
président brésilien des manifestations
pro dictature est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que jaillit un bol sonar ou
à des tentations autoritaires
oui exactement 1 bolton à rodez puis
plusieurs semaines a pris l'habitude de
participer à des manifestations qui
prône la suppression du congrès la
suppression aussi de la cour suprême et
qui demandent une intervention militaire
vous les participants réclament tosti
une application des lay 5 c'est un des
décrets le plus dur de la dictature
brésilienne et ces rassemblements lors
de ces rassemblements pardon golden
arrow a proclamé des phrases très
inquiétante
comme la constitution 1 c'est moi ou
alors les forces armées sont à côté de
la population brésilienne et donc même
si l'armée a déjà dit officiellement que
son rattachement à exprimer par dont son
attachement profond à la démocratie et à
la liberté
les politologues breizh
lien ce sont des montrer très très
inquiet ces dernières semaines et ils
craignent un processus d'érosion de la
démocratie au brésil merci à augusta
lunardi d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur ft france le monze déconfite donc
peu à peu le sénégal décide lui aussi
d'assouplir ces mesures de restriction
le pays en rappel enregistre un nombre
de décès très faible par rapport aux
états unis ou à l'europe 19 depuis le
début de l'épidémie
pas de confinement strict dans ce pays
donc mais des mesures relativement
sévère tout de même qu'ils se sont
assouplies voir retirer parmi elles la
réduction du couvre-feu et la
réouverture des lieux de culte cyrielle
bruit pour la troisième fois depuis le
début de la pandémie
le président macky sall s'est adressé au
peuple sénégalais
cette fois ci le chef de l'état a décidé
de présenter une nouvelle phase de la
lutte contre le coc vite 19
il propose ainsi un assouplissement des
restrictions mises en place dans le pays
aujourd'hui après deux mois de mise à
l'épreuve
nous devons seulement adapter notre
stratégie en tenant compte une fois de
plus de notre vécu quotidien
dans cette nouvelle phase qui va durer
non pas quelques semaines vers au moins
trois à quatre mois
nous devons désormais apprendre à vivre
en présence du virus
en adaptant nos comportements
individuels une adaptation des
comportements nécessaires face à un
virus susceptible de circuler encore
jusqu'en septembre au sein du pays
le couvre-feu mis en place depuis le 23
mars dernier est réduit de deux heures à
partir de ce mardi une mesure qui
s'accompagne d'un allègement des
restrictions dans les transports en
commun les commerces eux pour ouvrir six
jours sur sept afin de consacrer une
journée entière au nettoyage des locaux
nous avons des équipes de terrain qui
ont des engins motorisés et des objets
manuel pour dépenser des infections de
tout ce qui est porte tout ce qui est
surface au sol tout ce qui est
rayonnages tout ce qui est caddie pour
justement éviter que le virus se propage
sur le sur le spa marché nous avons bien
spécifié alors à l'entreprise qui est en
charge de cette mission de nous proposer
un produit efficace contre le coup du 19
mai qui n'altère pas la santé des
populations ni la terre par la qualité
des produits que nous vendons la
réouverture des lieux de culte est
également au programme afin de permettre
les prières essentiel en plein mois de
ramadan dans un pays à 90% musulman
une partie des élèves reprendra le
chemin de l'école à partir du 2 juin
prochain
selon le président macky sall 10
millions de masques fabriqués au sénégal
seront prochainement distribués à la
population afin de limiter au mieux
l'avancée du virus reste avec nous dans
quelques instants à nous reviendrons sur
l'hypothèse de la création à l'assemblée
nationale d'un groupe dissident de la
république en marche et nous parlerons
de laisser européenne discovery qui doit
nous permettre d'accélérer la recherche
d'un traitement entre locaux vides 19
mai dont les résultats se font attendre
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons terme la stratégie de
conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
face à ce type de pratiques il n'existe
sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doivent selon vos
jouets à lévis lesquels rôle joue-t-elle
dans les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles courent transformé après
la pandémie la crise maintenant à fait
bien comprendre qu'on paie pas s'oublier
des banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas pas seulement d'elle
même elle parle aussi de comment créer
un cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
une deuxième heure d'émission 21h heure
de paris tout de suite voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 12 mai
va-t-on assister à l'éclosion d'un
neuvième groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale selon nos
confrères des échos
quelques dizaines de députés pourraient
former un groupe dénommé écologie
démocratie solidarité
si les spéculations vont bon train ce
groupe ne se passeraient ni dans la
majorité ni dans l'opposition mais
pourrait bien fragilisé la république en
marche
discovery un nom synonyme d'espoir alors
que la pandémie se propage les résultats
de l'essai clinique européen eux se font
attendre promis le 14 mai par emmanuel
macron le rendu des travaux pourrait
être plus tardif alors que quatre
traitements sont au coeur de laisser
européen pénurie de patients aux
problèmes de budget sont cités pour
expliquer le retard
[Musique]
elle montre d'abord sur le bilan de
l'épidémie coronavirus en france avec
près de 27000 décès au total selon les
chiffres de la direction générale de la
santé ce soir 348 personnes sont mortes
en 24 heures le nombre de patients en
réanimation continue de baisser avec 170
malades en moins le nombre de personnes
guéries est sorti de l'hôpital s'établit
lui à 57100 785 depuis le début de
l'épidémie
un groupe dissident c'est ce que
recherche serait donc à créer des
députés la république en marche il
pourrait voir le jour la semaine
prochaine selon nos confrères les échos
il sort et plusieurs dizaines et vouloir
former écologie démocratie solidarité
parmi eux des marcheurs et des ex
marcheurs ils auraient également aidé
écologistes ses députés un frondeur
déplore notamment le plan de relance et
de transformation de la france et de
l'europe
toujours selon les échos écologie
démocratie solidarité pourrait donc être
le neuvième groupes parlementaires du
palais bourbon
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
nous sommes également avec frédéric
sinclair éditorialiste ancien conseiller
politique de dominique de villepin
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors un groupe dissident à
nouveau à la république en marche en
pleine crise sanitaire est ce que cela
vous surprend-il arnaud benedetti à vau
l'eau d'heure écoutez c'est finalement
toute l'ambiguïté de la démarche des
malades emmanuel macron depuis le début
emmanuel macron est partis du centre
gauche
ça a été d'ailleurs son socle à la fois
et idéologiques et électorale et sa
pratique du pouvoir depuis qu'il a
accédé à l'elysée
la progressive mans est constamment
déportés vers le centre droit et donc il
est naturel que dans une période qui est
une période difficile après trois ans le
mandat avec des événements sociaux comme
les gilet jaune qui ont profondément
bousculé l'exécutif qu'une partie de son
aile gauche se pose des questions sur la
ligne politique du président de la
république alors évidemment ça va
fragiliser mathématiquement si ce groupe
se crée la majorité parlementaire qui
deviendrait dépendante à la fois du bon
vouloir de ce groupe mais également du
bon vouloir du modem qui dispose d'à peu
près d'une cinquantaine de
parlementaires
frédéric saint clair vous vous êtes
surpris par ce projet je j'ai consacré
en 2019 mon premier édito de l'année
janvier 2019 en pleine crise des gilets
jaunes
à ce sujet je pensais qu'en 2019 sarris
produire et donc j'avais pronostiqué une
fracturation de l'électorat macro nist
auquel je ne trouvais déjà aucune unité
je trouve que manuel macro ont plutôt
bien résisté à la crise des gilet jaune
et c'est la crise du coc vide qui
finalement fracture ce socle qui est
composite arnaud bennet hilale a rappelé
emmanuel macron a glissé lentement de la
gauche vers la droite et il n'a jamais
fait mystère de sa volonté d'aggloméré
différents pans de la société politique
et civile
ce qui pose évidemment des problèmes en
matière de cohésion et ses problèmes
allaient de toute façon se révéler pour
pour modérer quand même ce départ
ces gens là ont besoin d'exister ils ont
un agenda politique propre et s'ils
s'inscrivent dans une opposition bête et
méchante
ils n'existeront plus et peuvent
provoquer une crise politique beaucoup
plus grave qui peut conduire à une
dissolution
donc c'est pas leur intérêt parce qu'ils
pourraient perdre leur siège donc il
faut pas non plus
surinterpréter cette fracture on ne suit
rentes et repas mais il n'empêche on se
souvient tous des frondeurs qui ont
causé beaucoup de tort aux prédécesseurs
d'emmanuel macro un françois hollande
arnaud benedetti le moment est tout de
même grave pour un emmanuel macron déjà
fragilisés ont visé par la crise et
gilet jaune évidemment et maintenant par
cette crise du coroner virus
oui parce que c'est un moment compliqué
au monde
à l'instant il va falloir qui le gère
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
le pays compte d'autres pays européens
va être confronté en déchets à une crise
économique et sociale vraisemblablement
sans précédent donc gérer cette crise
avec une majorité qui est soudainement
prise d'un certain nombre de problèmes
de conscience c'est bien évidemment une
équation qui est beaucoup plus difficile
donc emmanuel macron aujourd'hui se
retrouve confronté aux limites de
l'exercice
si vous voulez la démarche de
rassemblement qui était la sienne est
une démarche de rassemblement qu'il a
construite autour d'un certain nombre
d'idées qui finalement constitué le plus
petit dénominateur commun pour faire
tenir ensemble des gens venant
d'horizons différents le rassemblement
c'est toujours quelque chose de complexe
lorsque valéry giscard d'estaing a
essayé en dans les années 70 lui aussi
de lancer sa fameuse formule de deux
français sur trois il se repose
néanmoins sur un groupe parlementaire
qui restait malgré tout à socle solide
malgré un allié gaulliste qui durant
tout le mandat
en tout cas la seconde partie du mandat
lui a causé bien des difficultés lorsque
le général de gaulle rassembler il avait
une majorité parlementaire qui était
extrêmement solide et puis il y avait
surtout des militants qui étaient des
militants chevronnés des parlementaires
qui étaient chevronnés
là en l'occurrence manifestement on est
quand même aussi avec un groupe
parlementaire dont il ne faut jamais
oublier qu'il n'a pas le degré de
professionnalisation et
vraisemblablement de conscience
militante que les groupes parlementaires
mme d'autres président de la république
avaient en leur temps
alors l'homme
on sait démocratie écologie solidarité
les mots ont un sens évidemment c'est
pas vous je vais l'apprendre frédéric
saint clair ça veut dire quoi qui
manquait pour ses députés un peu de
démocratie un peu d'écologie un peu de
solidarité
oui il manquait de la gauche il manquait
un emmanuel macron avec une main gauche
il avait de main droite donc il ya un
vrai problème de droitisation du
président de du point de vue de sa
majorité
pas du point de vue de son électorat et
c'est là que se noue toute la
problématique des manuels macron pour
les mois à venir c'est que le risque de
fracturation majeur au niveau de la glas
de sa majorité donc à l'assemblée pour
le vote des lois se situe sur sa gauche
et son électorat se situe sur sa droite
et donc soit il continue de satisfaire
son électorat avec une communication et
jeudi d une communication de plus en
plus droitière qui lui montre que l a
bien compris les problématiques liées à
la relance économique à l'accumulation
de richesses à la protection des
frontières à la souveraineté où vous
avez vu notamment le terme dans l'année
qui a vu du financial times exploser
littéralement un répéter un nombre de
fois incalculable donc là il
il ouvre une porte très très large sur
tout c'est ce nouvel électorat potentiel
souverainistes dont une large partie est
à droite donc il se met directement en
concurrence avec marine le pen
et puis pour comme pour l'embêter et
bien c'est sur sa gauche que ça se
fracture à l'assemblée il va falloir les
voter ces lois et à ce moment là il va
falloir rallier le côté gauche si
emmanuel macron veut faire plaisir à ce
groupe frondeur il risque de déplaire à
son à son électorat il est vraiment à
coincer j'allais dire entre deux feux
arnaud benedetti pourtant emmanuel
macron à nous l'a promis il faut se
réinventer en parlant de 7 après crise
du commis de 19 et moi le premier at il
dit ça veut dire qu'il va plutôt
basculer sur sa gauche emmanuel macron
l'avenir difficile de dire c'est qu'il
est sur une ligne 2
être bien inconfortable aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que l'électorat
d'emmanuel macron s'est droitisée
regardez les résultats des dernières
élections européennes et quand coup vous
vous observez les scores obtenus par la
liste conduite par madame l'oiseau ce
sont des scores qui sont importants dans
des zones qui sociologiquement et
territorialement sont plutôt à droite
voire en tout cas au centre droit donc
il y à un exercice qui est extrêmement
compliquée où on voit un emmanuel macron
qui historiquement quand même par du
centre gauche il faut jamais oublier
quand même qu'il a été secrétaire
général ministre le secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée ministre de de
françois hollande et qui progressivement
à vue s'agréger vers sa marque
électorale tout une sociologie
électorale tu es plutôt disons de
centre-droit donc c'est très difficile
pour lui d' arbitrer entre eux
finalement ces parlementaires qui
viennent de la gauche et cette nouvelle
sociologie électorale qui vient plutôt
de la droite et il va de soi que ayant
quand même grillé une partie de ces
vaisseaux à gauche depuis trois ans ça
va être extrêmement difficile pour lui
tu de reconquérir un électorat qui
aujourd'hui les semblablement ne lui
fait pas confiance parce que ils
considèrent qu'ils mènent ils plutôt que
politique que la politique pour laquelle
éventuellement il a été élu et surtout
parce que aujourd'hui il est lui même
d'une certaine façon aussi concurrencer
sur sa droite sur un certain nombre de
thématiques qui l'a remis au goût du
jour qui sont les thématiques de
souveraineté mais qu'il ne peut pas
véritablement payante et parce que
d'autres forces politiques depuis
maintenant suffisamment longtemps on
préempte systématique
un dernier thème que je voulais être
regardés avec vous messieurs et le
premier ministre dans tout ça on a
longuement commenté les tensions les
pseudos tension en tout cas avec
emmanuel macron qui ont été démenties
par ce dernier
les rumeurs de changement ces derniers
jours quel est votre point de vue sur ce
point frédéric saint clair vous pensez
que edouard philippe ne va pas finir ce
quinquennat
alors ne va pas je ne peux pas vous le
dire j'ai pas pas ma boule de cristal
avec moi ce soir mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que si emmanuel macron
veut réellement se détacher de cette
pénible crise du coc vide qui va
psychologiquement un impact et la
mentalité des français et qui va se
traduire comme l'a dit arnaud benedetti
on est une crise sociale et économique
très rapidement et surtout en une crise
politique majeure
on est aux autos tout début d'une
profonde crise politique type gilet
jaune
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je le
vois c'est à dire quelque chose qui va
vraiment secoué l'opinion va ya voir se
rend pas encore compte maintenant mais
un profond sentiment de rejet c'est en
train de monter de plus en plus d'autres
dans l'opinion ce qui veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire que si emmanuel macron
veut anticiper un après il faut
absolument se séparer se couper de la
base de l'avant en partie donc ça veut
dire remodelé en gardant les figures qui
sont intéressantes et qui s'en sont bien
sortis pendant cette crise duco vide et
en écartant un certain nombre d'autres
figures et notamment la principale
edouard philippe donc si vraiment
emmanuel macron veut anticiper 2022 dans
les meilleures conditions il va falloir
qu'ils doivent philips on highway and
obesity est ce que vous partagez le
diagnostic l'analyse de frédéric cinq
heures parce qu'enfin en attendant
edouard philippe peuvent s'en sort un
peu mieux en termes de cote de confiance
que le président lui même
oui c'est bien toute la difficulté et la
complexité de la faire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on comprend que le môle
de stabilité et si ce n'est de cette
majorité mais en tout cas de cet
exécutif pour une partie de l'opinion
publique c'est edouard philippe et ce
n'est plus le président me et ce n'est
plus le président de la république
donc at-il intérêt de se séparer aussi
rapidement du premier ministre qui plus
tôt a fait le job dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles c'est une
question qui se pose à lui il trouvera
bien évidemment une solution de
substitution mais la vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui des manuels
des manuels macron elle est double c'est
qu' il est temps défiance en tout cas
l'opinion publique une grosse partie de
l'opinion publique une majorité de
l'opinion publique est en défiance
vis-à-vis de lui et il a aujourd'hui dix
ont une ligne de défiance à l'intérieur
même de sa majorité
donc il va falloir qu'ils se battent sur
deux fronts à la fois le front de
l'opinion et le front du parlement et
vous savez tous les généraux qui se sont
battus sur deux fronts en règle générale
ont perdu
c'est donc un exercice particulièrement
périlleux aujourd'hui auxquels il est
confronté
merci a tous les dehors nominé d'etigny
frédéric saint clair d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et si la
reprise du travail s'est fait hier
certaines entreprises se sont déjà
adaptés aux mesures barrières depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est le cas dans une
menuiserie au loroux-bottereau près de
nantes en loire atlantique tout le
fonctionnement de cette société a été
bousculé comme le montre ce reportage
sur place des stèles farges avec rolls
au parc est bouleversé ses habitudes
c'est le défi relevé par le personnel de
cette menuiserie de nouveaux rituels a
adopté dès l'arrivée sur le lieu de
travail ils diront le plan de
circulation
donc il arrive par cette porte il
s'équipe après en le pays et après ils
s'intègrent leurs postes de travail
le retour c'est pareil il ya tout un
circuit justement pour pas qu'ils
croisent les personnes qui arrivent
un point important c'est qu'on a mis en
place là où aujourd'hui on travaille en
régulière pour qu'ils aient moins de
personnes à l'instant t on a ouvert en
de witte l'ensemble des usines
et puis les personnes arrivent toutes
les deux minutes ils arrivent par deux
si les salariés de cette menuiserie ont
pu reprendre le travail le 8 avril
dernier c'est parce que pendant les
trois semaines de fermeture une équipe a
planché sur la réorganisation totale des
lieux en concertation avec le cso et la
médecine du travail 0 contact c'est
dorénavant le mot d'ordre ici un
opérateur ou une personne de bureau n'a
pas à toucher une seule poignée dans ce
genre de travail sert au contact donc
c'est pour ça qu'on voit dans le couloir
c'est pour ça qu'on voit ici toutes les
portes sont en matinée ouverte on
arrêter de demander aux personnes de
production de badji en arrivées et en
sortie ça évite justement que touche et
sur la validation sur une touche et
potentiellement de 2,2 contaminé de se
contaminer d'une personne à l'autre
aucun détail n'est laissé de côté
madison par exemple doit désinfecter son
poste de travail
après chaque vacation a fait un nouveau
rythme qu'on a plus depuis la reprise le
que tous les jours on arrive ou d un
fake
on s'est dit qu'on avait mais qu'on
repart le plus compliqué pour la jeune
femme c'est le manque d'interaction avec
ses collègues que ben y'en a pas quoi
tout simplement
mais bon après c'est les habitudes à
prendre pour notre sécurité en cas
d'oubli
il y à michael il est l'un des référents
qu'ovide de la menuiserie sa mission
informer mais aussi rassurer les
salariés
référent commune entre en compte a été
pour les premiers jours de travail
expliquer à chaque opérateur
comment utiliser les nouveaux
équipements comment faire pourquoi les
pauses sont décriés pourquoi ceci
pourquoi cela est dans le quotidien
c'est de rappeler les règles
surtout il pas oublier comme de
déconfinement va arriver que dans
l'entreprise les règles ne vont pas
évoluer
cent mille euros c'est la somme
déboursée par l'entreprise pour la mise
en place de tout le protocole de
sécurité
s'ajoutent à cela les pertes liées aux
trois semaines de fermeture en début de
confinement une facture salée pour les
menuiseries
aujourd'hui on estime à peu prendre une
perte à 2 millions cinq premiers au
dessus d'un fermier tout investissement
de 100 mille euros c'est une crise qui
commence à coûter cher
oui mais on espère que nous trois
activités de proactivité notre
réactivité notre anticipation de la
reprise va nous permettre de regagner
des parts de marché
certaines mesures adoptées pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire pourrait bien
perdurer dans cette menuiserie comme par
exemple le télétravail et où on est
l'essai clinique discovery coordonnée
par l'inserm est lancée en mars dernier
la pour ambition de tester des
traitements sur les patients gravement
atteints par le comique 19
un projet qui a du mal à se concrétiser
malgré l'optimisme du président mais
kron ce dernier promet t il y a quelques
jours des résultats d'ici le 14 mai les
détails en images
[Musique]
on
vous
[Musique]
non
vous
et
[Musique]
je
où
dray pour en parler nous retrouvons à
oxford au royaume uni martin landry et
épidémiologiste à l'université d'oxford
et directeur du big data institute c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir martin landry merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord un petit point sur l'essai
discovery dont on attend beaucoup
où en est-on concrètement nous venons
d'entendre que l'essai discovery
semblait être enlisée je l'entends de
vous mais également à mes propres
sources
il faut comprendre que cet essai n'est
qu'un laissez pas remis beaucoup de
grandes cliniques qui vise à essayer de
comprendre quels traitements
fonctionnent pour lutter contre le coc
vides il y en a beaucoup d'autres très
similaires dans le monde par exemple
l'un d'entre eux le pc solidarity menée
par l'om s est laissée recovery menée au
royaume uni
pourquoi est ce si compliqué d'avoir des
résultats pourquoi ça patine
selon vous la question de la lenteur ont
plutôt de des problèmes pour recruter
des patients avec l'essai discovery
c'est une question qu'il faudrait poser
aux personnes qui mènent laisser au
royaume uni le laisser recovery est très
semblable et étudie cinq médicaments
pour les patients admis à l'hôpital avec
le coc u19
nous avons mis en place et études très
rapidement la première description
scientifique assez fait neuf jours avant
le premier
le premier recrutement du premier
patient dans deux semaines elle laissait
été mise en place et nous avons plus de
9500 patients à ce jour donc il est haut
possible de mener des essais cliniques
relativement simple et très large qui
mèneront à des réponses faisant
heureusement il y avait une urgence en a
évidemment dû à cette crise du
coronavirus beaucoup dont emmanuel
macron en tête se montrent optimistes
attendent beaucoup tout de même de cet
essai discovery est ce que c'est votre
cas aussi vous pensez que ça va produire
des résultats tangibles
chaque chaque faits supplémentaires est
très important et c'est plus important
que c'est plus en tout cas efficace que
de donner des médicaments sans savoir
s'il fonctionne ou pas donc
effectivement les essais sont précieux
mais je dirais que vous avez raison
lorsque le coffee 10 9 a frappé paris ou
londres la mi mars
c'était un fardeau extraordinaire à
d'autres est lourde pour les services de
santé les médecins et également les
patients qui se porte mal qui sont très
inquiets pour leur santé et qui se
sentent seules à cause de la
distanciation être pour le mieux je
pense que l'un des secrets que nous
avons trouvé aurait lui c'est que les
essais doivent être simples à mettre en
place pour les docteurs pour les
infirmiers et pour les patients il faut
éliminer toutes les barrières qui
empêchent de prendre part à ces essais
ce ne sont que les essais cliniques qui
nous permettent de différencier les
médicaments prometteurs plein d'espoir
et les médicaments qui fonctionne
concrètement alors parmi les médicaments
dont on a en tout cas beaucoup parlé ici
en france il ya l'hydroxyde chloroquine
a prôné par le professeur à ault à
marseille
vous en tant que professionnel quels
sont les retours que vous en avez
précisément sur ce médicament dans le
cadre de l'essai discovery
cela fait des décennies qu'on utilise
l'hydroxyde leur queen par exemple pour
lutter contre la malaria
mais il n'y a pas de preuve qu'elle est
efficace face au collectif et il n'ya
pas non plus de preuve qu'elle ne
fonctionne pas il ya beaucoup de
spéculations et pas de fête
2 et pourtant les patients besoin de
fait concret de preuves
les docteurs les patients et ils ne les
obtient que grâce à ces essais cliniques
donc des essais randomisés à grande
échelle sur ce médicament et l'analyse
des résultats sur les patients c'est
vraiment le crucial afin de comprendre
s'il est toxique le au queen est un
traitement efficace inefficaces ou même
un traitement dangereux donc tous
spéculer nous n'avons pas besoin de
spéculation a besoin de connaissances à
votre avis l'europe a été unie dans ce
combat contre le coc vide 19s qu'on
communique acs qui l'y a suffisamment de
cohésion entre les différents pays je
pense que beaucoup d'efforts pour de la
cohésion et de la collaboration est
vraiment exceptionnel de cette crise
c'est la faculté des gens de travailler
ensemble alors qu'il ne l'avait jamais
fait auparavant
cela est vraiment très bon signe lui
mettant chacun de nos pays les problèmes
sont différents et même au sein des pays
les situations sont très différentes à
paris ce n'est pas une chose qu'à
bordeaux et à londres la situation est
différente par exemple à lille ou à
manchester ou birmingham
chaque ville a ses spécificités on peut
effectivement mettre en place une
coordination au niveau national et
international
mais les solutions doivent se trouver
sur le terrain dans les hôpitaux
individuelle et auprès des docteurs des
infirmiers et des patients si on ne les
appliquent pas si on en fasse une pas la
tâche à ces personnes qui prennent
vraiment en charge le fardeau alors il
ya des problèmes merci beaucoup martine
landais d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologiste à
l'université d'oxford directeur du big
data institute merci d'avoir été avec
nous et c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes minutes
pardon pour un point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
vous vous dites que ce délit de
violation du confinement n'est pas
conforme à la constitution
quant à eux ceux des comptes revient à 1
heure ou 1 2 principes majeurs sont
celui du principe d'égalité des délits
td et le principe de l'achat de première
nécessité qu'est ce qu'une ligne
familiales impérieuses
j'ai finalement délaissé à la libre
appréciation de l'agent et ça ne nous
prémunit pas contre 1 d'escaudes
arbitral et son partenaire déclaré qu'il
ne dit pas qu'il y ait des terreurs et
c'est parce que je ne doutais pas qu'il
y ait veillé à ce que le délai des
pompes des stations porte est à 4 et
c'est là où la présomption d'innocence
n'est pas respectable d'état un problème
je l'assumé les tests